good morning Millennials good morning
Rachel Lindsay oh sorry we're a little
late you know shucking and jiving when
you have the busiest woman because
that's one of your many jobs so it comes
naturally cute you look amazing so like
I just want to take a moment I'm
obsessed with everything your nails your
boots your sweater these are these are
very like New York slash it's Halloween
October nails they're spooky nails for
sure and they look good with your ring
thank you thank you I'm wearing revolve
of course Harlow because you're a
revolve girl you're nominated for a bomb
award it's not crazy that's amazing what
was the category it was like back out
ambassador of the Year breakup I still
can't believe it no that's amazing
voting is closed or else I would make
you all go right now and vote for Rachel
but I already did and I feel like you
could win thank you so fingers crossed
and maybe we'll have to like stuff the
ballot box get out the vote but you are
their breakout ambassador of the year
you post premium content we're so happy
to see you like in where'd they go
Bermuda Bermuda was so much fun it looks
so pretty
it was great I think I'm like I'm gonna
go now because of that trip which makes
scent like which is why the Bermuda trap
like Tourism Board like works with
revolves yeah you have to it's so close
I think people forget about it but once
you go you're gonna know that's
we're just in the Bahamas for my
Bachelorette and it's so close and I
feel like people forget about it because
it's like almost just like 10 minutes
further than Florida yeah and you're in
a different country with bluer beaches
and inks and it's real it's good stuff
so welcome to New York
you are here for revolve around the
world yes very exciting stuff how has it
been so far it's I just got here
yesterday
okay I've missed out because I am busy
but I like pick up right where I left
off which was in LA last time right and
it's like I'm not missing a beat revolve
LA looked really really fun because you
guys like have the pier and stuff there
well you're not LA anymore so I'm not
going to group you in with them but it
just looks lit and like New York I guess
because I live here I'm just like sour
about it I'm like where's our ferris
wheel yeah but we're doing ice skating
which can be fun that's cool
and it'll be key picture is good for the
flow yeah are you like I've become so
obsessed with Instagram flow like how my
feed looks like a like a nutjob a little
bit
you care about that stuff or you're just
like I'm posting the pictures that
please me yeah I made that face because
I did there was a time where I was like
my feet is Bob you look at my feet it is
ratchet
like my head dropped on someone else in
the picture with me they don't fit it's
a vest
well I'm like just trying to let people
know what I'm doing and yeah going off
on it being pretty it's I'm being bad no
it's really hard to be a blogger or an
influencer who posts in real time with
premium content without being on being a
person who's on your phone all the time
like just editing pictures in the moment
yeah but there's this new toasters group
it's called do it for the toast and you
post up your picture in there and you're
like him someone make this premium take
the people out of the back put a preset
on it etc and 50 girls will reply to
your Facebook post with an amazing
version of your photo you pick the best
one and post it so that's how I got into
like being obsessed with flow do a
further toast it's the best and then
like they have a hashtag so you can see
all the photos that were edited by do it
for the toast it's just interesting no
it makes it that they taught me about
presets do you use presets no I don't
even know okay that makes me feel better
cuz I feel like I'm so late to the game
but anyways you are here we are so happy
to have you and we're gonna get into the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I haven't had a
morning toast yet in them I'm not sure
oh yeah I'm hungry yeah that's like
after this ravenous first story there
are exciting news that I feel like
everyone saw coming because we all knew
a little something and maybe read too
many blind items but Jennifer Garner is
casually dating CEO John Miller says a
source he hasn't met her kids Jennifer
Garner is dating cali group CEO john
miller a source tells people they are
casually dating but it's not serious
garner shares three kids with ex-husband
Ben Affleck the news come shortly after
garner and Affleck finalized their
divorce three years after announcing
they were ending their 10-year marriage
in June 2015 the couple began dating in
2004 and married in June 2005 before
simultaneously filing for divorce in
April 2017 so it seems as though putting
the pieces together with like you know a
careful eye that they've been dating for
a while and she waited until her divorce
was finalized to announce it I'd like
her first of all the most shocking thing
and that whole article to me is that she
has three kids
I thought they had two I did
i I know Sarafina because that's a name
you don't forget violet Sarafina and
Samuel I guess it makes sense why I
think they have to cuz like Samuel
doesn't is like one of these names is
unlike the others yeah one of these
names is biblical and the rest are
restaurants in New York I love her I
think I love the way that she's handling
this divorce how she's moving along how
she kept this quiet now it's coming out
you're right they've probably been
dating for a while she's truly living
her best life like she's going this way
and Ben's going this way it's it's sad I
actually I really liked them together
and I really was holding out hope for
them and it it seemed as though they
were kind of pulling at our heartstrings
by letting us think that they might be
getting back together for three years
we're gonna get back to really I felt
like they were doing it for the children
which is always a good reason to do it
but I feel like her dating a businessman
is it is a good move I think like do you
can't go from like one of the most
famous couples in the world like both
huge celebrities to like dating another
huge celebrity it's like to hire some
right I think she's over it I love that
she has someone who's not in Hollywood
low-key she seems like a low-key person
she does with her Capital One
commercials she like you know just you
know will take that commercial money and
live a nice life and her businessman
boyfriend will invest it for her it is a
dream perfect match
it does everyone needs to follow suit
totally and he's cutie yeah he is cute
google him and she looks amazing she
does look amazing
she really does I mean I wish her movies
were getting better with time but what
love Simon was so good you know what I
didn't see it
okay oh and you know what I'm sorry and
oh no I confuse her with Julia Roberts I
was about to say wonder was so good but
that was Julia Roberts you see wonder no
I don't want to cry if you I only cried
in commercial actually I cried yeah
Claudia said the same thing she was
wailing from the trailer and she was
like I'm not gonna see them again
I just loved Jacob Tremblay and I want
to support him in all of his endeavors
did you see room yes oh I wanted him so
bad no taking fall he was so cute he's
the cutest little and he's in something
else I forget but room was our toast
movie of the week a few weeks ago and I
watched it for the first time and like
I'm still shook by it so I find a way to
work it into every conversation
Arsen so she's a big bachelor fan so
I've been to her house to like watch an
episode of the show exclusive never even
talked about that before that's amazing
the coolest low-key down-to-earth person
she seems cool and low-key cuz like she
was nominated for an Oscar did she win
and like she's not out here like
thirsting in the streets like she is
cool yeah she gives me like Jennifer
Lawrence vibes yeah have you met her
no okay do you like her I mean she's not
for everyone
yes and it's hard when like people like
push someone on you so much like then
you can't help but like then have a
visceral then dislike them because the
Machine is telling you to like them you
know what it is with her I feel like
she's always trying so hard to prove
that she's like just a regular girl and
you're not you're not just a regular
girl stop we get it let it speak for
itself
like Jennifer Garner doesn't do that no
Jennifer Garner doesn't do that and
she's not a regular girl either except
she's dating a regular man and I think
this is a great move and I also feel
like so many everyone like kind of knew
about this and was just waiting for the
news to officially drop it's weird how
news works like that it's like something
could be true but you won't like until
they announce it you can't talk about it
but did it say the article that she
hasn't met or he hasn't met her kids
yeah this is real life no totally it's
real life like she has a lot going on
Ben is still in treatment like she
doesn't want to like rattle things and
rattle her children and it's really like
normal way to go about it I like it I
like it too I think more sovereignty
should date like business people yeah I
think it's hard to be like two
celebrities in the same orbit yeah no I
don't think I could do it no but like
now you and Bryan are both celebrities
yeah but it's different I don't know I
don't really consider myself a celebrity
you're such a celebrity no you really
are like you I mean we're at primetime
ABC and the nose thing matters but
because I was gonna be like former
bachelor at Rachael Inslee and I was
like I feel like being the Bachelorette
is like being an Olympian like you're
not a former like you're always an
Olympian you are always a Bachelorette I
feel like it's always say it's like Miss
America yeah like it's like a pageant
you know like I feel like you're the
winner and then you pass the crown to
someone else no totally so then you say
former Miss America or yeah you just say
okay so then maybe
former bachelorette yeah and also we
posted a video this morning and every
time I hear the song that's my girl
I think of you and because that was your
promo song and it was just like so apt
and everyone like I was remember
watching and I'm like that's my girl and
then I was thinking back to like other
Bachelorette promo songs and like do I
feel that same Association and Rebecca
it was a woman by Kesha I'm a
[ __ ] woman but but Claudia and
I took umbrage with that choice and then
for Jojo it was confident by Demi Lovato
oh really yeah good that's a good song
but still it doesn't have that same like
you know what it was I have like a
full-out music video to go with mine we
build it like a music video so I think
that's why that is so fun yeah that's
like the dream did you guys do you have
a say in the song or no they were like
that's my girl that's it I listened to
it and I immediately like went into the
mode like I hear the song now and I'm
just like that's your theme song do you
feel that way too
yeah okay good oh wow that's great like
I'll be walking down the street
listening to I'm like that's amazing
okay next story is like I love stories
like this because only page six could
have it because it's about the teeny
tiny my new shoe drama that goes on
between the housewives while they're
filming housewives stars feud over galas
eating the Real Housewives of New York
City just started filming season eleven
and the ladies are already bickering at
fancy galas spies saw Ramona Singer and
Dorinda medley arguing over seating
arrangements at Denise Rich's costume
noble tequila sponsored angel ball
Ramona had invited Dorinda and told her
they would be seated at the same table
but upon arrival Dorinda was actually
seated at a separate table and appeared
upset that's when Ramona blamed it on
the organizers but the organizers told
Dorinda that it was singer who requested
a seat change another source told us
that Ramona appeared to be in a social
climbing mood I'm sure it'll all play
out on their show they had cameras
following them I can say one thing with
certainty I have never been in a social
climbing mood I don't even know what
that is now when you're just like I
don't know just feeling like aggressive
like I'm just hot I wish I were actually
better at social climbing like
networking you know moving up in the
world networking is
the same as social no I actually just
saw him the other day that was like
social climbing is unacceptable no
networking is just like an acceptable
form of social climbing okay maybe to a
point to a two degree I guess divert
tell you I met Ramona I don't think so
and maybe this was social climbing but I
met Ramona last year at Fashion Week she
comes running up it she was like they
tell me you're the Bachelorette and I
need to take a picture with you and so
she comes over and I'm like you know I'm
like oh my god I love the housewife this
is Ramona Singer I've been watching you
for ten years we take a picture she
might have been a little toasted okay
and she then takes my number or takes my
managers number thinks she's sending the
picture to her manager she sends it to
my manager and she's like look it's me
and the Bachelorette posted everywhere
put it on my social page maybe I could
be the next Bachelorette this is not
alive this is a true story maybe I could
be I'm dead obviously that would be
premium as hell from Colton to Ramona I
mean we have Colton why not right how do
you feel that Colton on that was Shady
so you know I have been very I really
wanted it to be Blake oh I've always
been very vocal about that even go back
at see I guess they've gone back twice
they had to pick someone they had to for
like for us I really didn't like the
going back even though I did eventually
like Ari Nick I mean well I mean Nick
work out for me because right I met
great girls
I went far right but all those girls
probably still would have been there and
but then who knows how far he would have
gone exactly right exactly but I
definitely am NOT a big fan of of Colton
The Bachelor well I'm I actually would
have been happy with Blake also I know a
lot of people wanted Jason I like Jason
too I happen to turn off men tell all
before he got to like his speech that
really changed hearts and minds so I it
was very I remember after the speech I
thought well that was a good pitch to me
this [ __ ] I have to watch it but then I
might want him to be the next Bachelor I
think it was genuine but it was like
like I watched it I was like man how's
she passed up on that one he's a good
guy yeah and he really flew under the
for most of the Remora but we just
didn't see it yeah I liked like - he
needs like some shine and he needs a
nice girl cuz he just has so much love
to give but then there were like rumors
going around that Vanessa is dating
Jason Vanessa yeah it actually make a
really cute couple
you think so made up you've made up
happy to hear it yeah we had a full
conversation it was really really good
that's great
actually I'm spoken why am I giving you
all these like exclusives I've spoken
about that just like sitting here
chillin and then like things just happen
but also I don't think people realize
like that you had major beef with
Vanessa because they never really aired
it yeah because if you're gonna be the
next Bachelorette and she's gonna be the
winner you can't be like in the drama
yeah yeah so like you never really saw
anything but I just think it's like that
show can bring out the best in the worst
of you and that's what I'm what we
talked about and I was like this is the
perfect time for us to have this
conversation because a year ago I said I
don't think I would have been ready and
I don't think you were - cuz she was
coming off her breakup with Nick I was
moving on with Bachelorette so now it's
like she's in a good place I am - so we
had like a really nice mature
conversation that is so nice yeah
are you cool with everyone from your
season yeah that's great you had a great
season of girls Nick was unworthy oh my
god in the last time you were here you
it was before powered I think you were
saying that you were so excited for
Astrid don't you love her I'm in love
with her she can't her and Kevin came on
the show and like they're the world's
most beautiful people and you've you
even like undersold how I mean like she
was everything I'm paradise like my
snitch and I were dead over her and
Kevin like they were so cute I know and
she was just so cool like her reactions
to everything her narration of
everything like just now I like I so get
it we are like this so I mean she was in
my limo the first night on next season's
and six or Nick season and we've been
cool ever since like super close I'm
probably the closest to a strip that's
amazing yeah well now she's gonna move
to Canada I
I literally go when I heard that she was
dating Kevin I texted Alexis and I go if
this [ __ ] moves to Canada we're done
we're done with her I know he would move
to Dallas no no she's going to Canada
it's
I'm queen of Canada I know which is
Toronto which is great totally and you
know they have a big airport like we can
visit back yeah no I mean I'm okay with
it now but at the time I was like no
don't leave us
but yeah was for everyone to move to
Dallas and it's working yeah you have
you a master play or even an atom mm-hmm
Alexis mm-hmm who else is there
Jojo I was like Jojo I know you're not
like in the group with Jojo yeah and
then they have they're like new show
have you seen any and see it have you
know I don't know where to watch it like
it's on like I don't know if it's on TV
or like a web it's here it's a web
series but I don't know where right
toasters I'm sure can can suss it out it
looks cute they're cute they've really
proven themselves you know yeah and I
think what's great is they were so
low-key they haven't talked about their
relationship so you really are getting
even though it's like two years ago
you're still getting like the inside
scoop of how they worked through their
relationship so I think it's good I feel
interesting
you know also now that you're in like
the ESPN world do you see Jordan a lot
like no I saw Jordan I met Jordan last
year at an ESPN event Jojo was there so
I was texting Jojo and she's like Jordan
I'm here with Jordan but I haven't I
don't see him because he does college
and I do NFL got it
she said it nothing okay next story is
wild news but megyn kelly is expected to
end her NBC morning show according to
The Hollywood Reporter give it up a year
in the making the anchor had met with
network executives to discuss covering
more news and politics megyn kelly is
expected to wind down her 9:00 a.m.
today show hour by the end of the season
a source close to the situation tells
The Hollywood Reporter like if it's if
they're telling The Hollywood Reporter
they're close to graduation
yeah sources tell thr that kelly has met
with network executives in recent weeks
to discuss the future of the show and
expressed a desire to cover more news
and politics it's unclear what NBC News
would put in place of Kelly's show if
you're looking for a premium Morning
Show to attract younger viewers I have
like one great idea but the discussions
are at least an acknowledgment that the
experiment is not working and that kelly
would prefer to be covering more news as
she did with the brett cabin our
hearings kelly has grappled with hard
news topics and
me too allegations against a series of
powerful men but her show isn't
typically a soft day part and she often
seemed to chafe at the lighter
requirements of the job Kelly met with M
EC news chairman Andy lack well before
the controversy over her recent
blackface comments erupted this week but
her clumsy comments about blackface on
Tuesdays megyn kelly today for which she
apologized have only exacerbated the
situation which was apparently already
right yes controversy yeah I think this
makes sense across the board and then
this is just like the nail in the coffin
yeah it's like no one wants her to be
doing a morning show she doesn't want to
be doing a morning show i I when they
announced that she was getting her show
I thought why and I liked her
but I thought she's not daytime TV no
she's not warm and inviting and like
she's like hard-hitting news right like
you can take her at in the evening but
in the morning like I need so I'm like
Kelly Ripa came to wake you the [ __ ] up
yeah same with Claudia and I I don't
know if I want Megan Kelly as my alarm
clock
well I know that I don't actually she's
your snooze button which is why people
are passing her but you know totally and
but she has a three year contract with
NBC for 20 million dollars a year she's
only a year and a half into it but even
if they can't her show like they'll have
to pay her out so I wonder if they'll
move her to later segment I feel like
they would have before the comments from
this week like they would have tried her
at nighttime next season but now she
might just be out totally she might
seriously she might be blackballed yeah
her agency dropped it yes CAA dropped
her I mean I don't know where you go
from here and when I heard that she made
the comments I thought do you want to be
kicked off TV right is this year out did
you do this on purpose because you're
smarter than that and then I thought was
this on the agenda or did you just go
rogue like what producer said we're
gonna talk about this and what are your
thoughts that's true because those shows
are very very structured yeah so you
really like and she's very teleprompter
heavy even though she muscles her way
through it or you must do at least maybe
she got better I don't know but now it's
like no one watched her show so no one
like saw what actually happened and if
she just like went rogue or this was
planned yeah you saw the backlash
because right no like you said and
watches it so we hear there's an opening
on TV we do and I know one show a couple
great hoes
who are very busy but can definitely
make room in their schedule for sure
you're the busiest woman ever we have so
many questions for you about like how
you manage your time but like you have
so many jobs and they're all legitimate
as hell like I'm a lawyer
being an ESPN host like all of these
things in their own right being an
influencer which is many people's full
time job in a very respectable career
yeah how do you how does she do it
I don't like I feel like I'm drowning
and I've recently been joking and I'm
like yeah I'm probably gonna have a
nervous breakdown next week you're like
Bethenny Frankel okay not so much that
might be the worst thing you ever said
like no I like her business was I was
just like not personal right because
like I know so she's taking on so much
and like she needs to do less yeah she's
so far you seem like good but it's
things are like it's hard because I'm on
the road so much and so I feel like I
can't give my all to things I feel like
I'm not as creative as I want to be I
don't take enough me time for myself
and like that's not good it's great to
be busy but like you also need some time
for yourself right so I and I'm engaged
and so it's hard Bryan and I literally
meet up in different cities
Miami LA he was just in New York it's
like we're never in Dallas together
because we're both doing so much so
[Laughter]
keeps things like fun and so when you
are in Dallas like I'm sure it's so nice
like Claudia's on tour right now and she
like is the happiest person when she's
home it's like yeah so it makes that
those moments like even more special it
does but it's hard and it's taxing it
and you look amazing while doing it I'm
so into you so much this is like makeup
on top of makeup on top of makeup I mean
still a lot of people wear makeup and
but you like you look wonderful
thank you Oh keep doing what you're
doing but also take time for yourself I
know I need to do better 2019 will be a
new year you'll probably see me pull
back from some things just because I
need to dedicate well I need to frickin
plan all right you're talking about this
right before we went live so everyone
wants to know when you're getting
married I want to know too like here's
the good news
okay Bryan and I are legit that's not
happening he's not going anywhere we're
not stalling coz we're having problems
like the one amazing thing in my life is
Bryan for sure hands down I just
take time to plan the weather it takes
so much time and setting a date and a
venue is the hardest part like for me it
took me six months to get there and I
was like in full wedding planning mode
at all times so I totally feel you and
if you're the busiest woman alive
already like adding a wedding planning
into the mix I know why it's not gonna
do it for me
yeah like I'm at the point now like
another exclusive at the point now where
it's like being 33 Brian being 38 we're
either gonna have to have like a 600
plus person wedding or it's gonna have
to be super small family only I'm moving
towards family only I'm thinking
overseas probably Italy super small like
50 people or less just family and like
most of my family they don't even have
passports so it's like they can't go
it's like cut stop and it's like I'll do
something later for the family at home
yeah but I think it's like super small
super close family like not even sorry
bachelor girls not even them it's like
they'll get it we'll make it up at the
bachelorette party right but just
intimate with the people who are gonna
be so influential in your life that's
what I think I'm gonna do it that sounds
so nice and if you do need a wedding
planner I have a great one
Oh we'll talk we'll talk I know sure oh
my god bachelor girls sorry sorry Alexis
Alexis was sitting here saying she's
gonna be listen if I'm fighting bachelor
girls alexis is at the top of the list
obviously obviously um where do you want
to do your back to our party Kartha
Haina ooh
Real Housewives of New York style would
you stay in that house I totally want to
be no not that house when they went to
the island yes that's what I want to do
oh my god you should stay there yeah
that's what I want cause it's like they
kind of have to make up for it after
what happened the disaster and good PR
yeah I'm sure that they would give it to
you that for a steal yeah that's what
but I but I wanted a wedding originally
in Colombia so I'm like forget that
stuff the bachelorette party there true
I mean is Brian Colombian mm-hmm that's
so nice and he should have his bachelor
party like on another island you guys
can like meet in the middle one day have
you ever seen the movie rough night is
which one there's so many like rough
night style movies is that the one where
with Kate McKinnon and yes I think she's
an Australian
and so yeah okay so you know like the
girls have a super wild party and then
they go to the guys and they're like
drinking wine they're like that's gonna
be my set up with Brian now that was my
Bachelorette and I feel like that's
gonna be Zach's bachelor party it's
gonna be like cigars like nice one nice
cute like he having legal Cuban cigar
exactly all right that's amazing
you know yours is gonna be wild so wild
I want swanee to film it I'm like this
is gonna be so epic know for sure except
then you don't want someone to build it
well it's like how do we erase the
footage yeah it's gonna have to be a
tight contract what you can and can't
show and are you make people sign NDA's
la la Ken style yeah I definitely had
people do that for other bachelorette
parties after all I've like created like
this full like contract and it's like
everybody's signed at the bottom like
you won't take pictures of certain
things you won't do yeah we could be
free uncomfortable and I guess with like
when you have different friends from
different like parts of your life yeah
it's hard to like feel comfortable
sometimes yeah be yourself be your wild
self yeah they're the best wild no
everyone needs like a trip like that
yeah you know and then it just makes you
like appreciate when you're bored like
you know what exactly being boring is
fun
it's 11:11 make a wish get your bag get
you back every day then wishing for a
Gucci bag and then like I haven't
stepped it up in like now I want an
Hermes croc even though I haven't really
did you bag yet but because this is my
theory about wish making wishes like
everyone wishes for like health
happiness etc but it's like you never
know if that wish came true
so like I like to make a tangible wish
like I want to lose five pounds this
month and I'll know if it came true yeah
I like that
no so Gucci bag it's a Gucci bag shows
them at my door I'll know that 11:11
works if a Gucci bag shows up in your
door for 11:11 I'm wishing I'm sitting
about alarm at 11:11 everything okay
next story is actually super interesting
Scooter Braun explains why he'll stay
quiet about Ariana Grande's past shitty
boyfriend's scooter Braun's longtime
relationship with client ariana grande
once took a turn thanks to one of her
quote shitty boyfriends the talent
manager who reps crime a as well as
Justin Bieber Carly Rae Jepsen
dan + Shay Tori Kelly and more revealed
during a talk at Fast Company's
innovation
Valon Tuesday that grande actually fired
him in early 2016
do two and then romance Variety reported
while he didn't name names as to who
grande was dating at the time scooter
said he made the choice back then to
wait for grande to see the light quote I
could have said a lot of stuff and in
fact my team wanted me to because they
were so pissed I think that's what the
people act out word like it's really
that crazy of a word we're not gonna say
a word and this is gonna come back
around he said they were like never take
her back and I just said let's stay
quiet and let our truth be our actions
eventually grande did but only after her
relationship ended quote when the shitty
boyfriend leaves she starts to see the
light on some stuff and one day I got a
phone call she said can I see you
tomorrow and I said no I'm busy I
actually couldn't talk so I said I could
see you Thursday or whatever and when I
went over there we had a very honest
conversation so then it also came out
that a year later or scooter and Ariana
leaned on each other after the
Manchester attack the relationship we
had from being fired and getting back
together really gave us a string for
what we never imagined would come that
following year that's like such a nice
story I need to know who the shitty
boyfriend was well 2016 right like can
we sheets it together is that big Shan
Shan like feels so long ago that might
have been Mac Miller
but then she was with Mac after
Manchester maybe that just brought them
all together
maybe I max oh maybe it was that guy
that she was dating when they said not
to bring it back to this because like
people change but um the thing about the
doughnuts I was just what for that yeah
he seems like a dick yeah would you like
a dancer yeah it never works with the
dancer no it never works with a dancer
and never works when like you're
someone's making you an [ __ ] mm-hmm
and saying that stuff so I feel like
that could have been the shitty
boyfriend I think that's who it was
and then we don't have to like Shirley
was with the fact that like be shocked
ya know it was a shitty boyfriend I
really liked them together I did too
and I never understood why they quite
broke up it was like a lyric in a song
or something like that she didn't like I
don't she let go so hard for her for her
men which is like really sweet but it
really has me convinced ohad for me to
make peace with their breakups like I'm
still shook over Pete Davidson I know
I'm leaving you never
it was nobody to obviously I believe
things can happen quickly I went on The
Bachelor for good to say so it's like
yes it can work but I don't know I just
never was it was too much it's too heavy
I didn't feel it what did you think it
was I may be a reaction to her breakup
with Mac Miller like yeah sometimes you
know you get in another relationship to
get over another one yeah I mean when I
went on The Bachelor originally I was
like new I was in a bad relationship and
it was dead but I kept going back to it
I was like how do I get over it ah go on
reality TV to go date a man yeah have a
whole new set of things to deal with
just to get over it I think that's what
it was did that help
yeah oh yeah I knew it was done I don't
know but like I guess getting also out
of your house and all the things I used
to do together like in a whole new it
was the setting right and then you're
just traveling the world yeah I want to
go to Bimini and they want to stay in
her house you've got to go to Bimini and
if anybody ever wants to get over a
breakup just apply to The Bachelor
that's the way to do it that's really
good advice like actually great I mean
it's a very select site pool but you
never know yeah you they look for like
if someone's applying for The Bachelor
what tips would you give them okay so I
actually get this question quite a bit
and I went to an actual audition so it's
like I could see my competition
interesting and when I went I was the
only one that looked like me not just
because I was black because I was in
flip-flops
I had like a tank top on and I was in
flowy pants I had a very minimal make up
all the other girls were like decked out
and like dresses form-fitting dresses
their best designer bags like like they
were going I don't know like to the club
and not season I feel like ice it was
definitely plot season I was like I fit
out because I was just more low-key yeah
and I remember the other people who were
in line with me because there was a line
that was the line we're in like workout
clothes sweats and so I think it's just
like be yourself don't go over the top
and don't try to be another Bachelorette
or something else or just be too eager
to be on the show like I was just kind
of like yeah I'm Rachel and I'm I'm an
attorney what are you doing here my
friends signed me up I'm not quite sure
why I'm here got it that's so
interesting so I read Andy Dorfman's
book and she pretty much said the same
like her friends were making her go she
came from work she wasn't even sure that
day that she was gonna go round up there
in her work attorney clothes and she did
not seem like everyone else so it really
is like less is more yeah and then what
would be your advice once you're in once
you're one of 25 or 30 girls what's your
advice here becoming the Bachelorette
well you have to have a story okay like
people have to realize that and not just
like oh you know like I suck at love you
really have to have a story of how you
kind of got here gift of a journey
keyword of how you got on the show you
know like what's been your trouble in
relationships and you know like what you
where you want to go now you kind of
have to be a hopeless romantic and just
open for love like that's the story I
feel like every Bachelorette unless you
were like a Becca or a Jojo where it's
just like pure heartbreak mm-hmm like
for everyone else it was kind of like
I'm I suck at opening up you know like I
finally did it
I had which is true this really was me I
suck it opening up I finally did it I
get here and then you like break my
heart you know I need another
opportunity to find love got it that's
like the best typical Bachelorette story
yeah cuz and it's also usually not the
person that was like burned like this
right the second place person because
they almost seemed like too upset to be
the Bachelorette I said the same thing
about Becca you did say that yeah I was
like I hope she's over him like truly
over him because it's hard to think
you're gonna spend the rest of your life
with someone
for two months and then they leave you
for the other woman and they were
talking to this other woman the whole
time that's like worse than the typical
runner-up because you never were engaged
you never knew for certain that it was
you yeah that's very true but her and
Garrett scene I mean just from Instagram
and everyone seems happy on Instagram
yeah but they like they seem very happy
no they do seem like a really good fit
mm-hmm together yeah just like smart
they're a smiley couple yeah that's I
don't think I've seen Karen not smile
but even when he was crying he was
smiling yeah he's just smiley dude I
don't know like I feel like people would
say I'm smiley but I don't know that I'm
not
you know I think you have like you can
have a resting [ __ ] this time for
sure but not now that I have my fresh
Botox it's better I'm obsessed I just
react last week and so I have very
little movement it I've never had Botox
I'm like afraid to and Astrid it's like
she's like yeah you could use it here
and here and I'm like actually that's a
real friend
it's looking at your partner I was gonna
ask you but then I didn't put you on the
spot I don't know no nobody look you're
no your forehead looks amazing thank you
and also I say do you say forehead or
forehead forehead I say fire head I have
a big forehead oh so I feel like if I
get Botox it's gonna be like even bigger
oh don't ask me why I think that I just
did I have a big fire I had to but
mostly because my eyelashes are my
eyebrows are so light that it looks like
part of the forehead gotcha you know I
love that you say forehead I know people
like wet the first time I said on the
show cue like what did you just say and
now I recognize that it's weird but I'm
not gonna change just Claudia say
forehead
yeah I think so like you know I don't
know we should put that out there like
where does that come from does anyone
else is it a New York thing yeah
sar Hedden I don't know anyway so okay I
used to like cross my eyebrows all the
time even when just I was sedentary and
people would think I was angry like Zach
was always what's wrong
like nothing just that you're asking
like ask me again ask me again
okay our fifth and final story some biz
news for the day Facebook gets maximum
fine over it's big data scandal data or
data I say data no I say data
it took me I go back and forth I don't
know what I say oh so right when I'm on
my phone and I'm like low on data I say
data but it Facebook is having a data
scam I don't know
I don't either it's like I'm gonna pay
today CNN business reports it won't even
notice UK authorities have hit Facebook
with a maximum possible fine over its
Cambridge analytical scandal but the
penalty is tiny
the UK's Information Commissioner's
Office announced the 500 thousand pound
six hundred and forty five thousand
dollar fine on Thursday saying that
Facebook failed to safeguard user data
data and was slow to contain the leak
the watchdog launched his investigation
earlier this year after it emerged that
Cambridge analytical access information
from
as many as 87 million Facebook users
without their permission
Facebook said in the statement that it
was reviewing the decision okay so like
a six hundred thousand dollar fine for
Facebook like that is nothing Elon Musk
got slapped with more for tweeting
something meanwhile you gave out eighty
seven million people's information
luckily for us they wouldn't use the
space but yeah I'm confused
like I guess I'm like the story keeps
going and going and going and I'm like
did they leak stuff again are we still
just talking about the exact same story
okay I think this is what happened so
there was the Cambridge analytical
scandal and I think things that's why
Mark Zuckerberg was in DC like being sad
in front of the Senate gotcha
and the result of this now is six
hundred and forty five thousand dollars
so coming however in between those there
was another Facebook hacking and I
remember everyone was logged out of I
everyone was logged out of their
Facebook you had to log back in and
that's a whole nother thing so they're
just there all over the I don't even
know my facebook password like Instagram
when it's like do you want to link this
to Facebook it's always like in your
password and I'm like oops can't
nevermind
because this is what I was thinking like
you're a celebrity do you still use
Facebook I feel like celebrities aren't
on Facebook no I don't I don't use it
and it used to be on my phone so I was
like oh I'll just scroll up all like I'd
like look at the feed but now I'm locked
out because I don't know my password and
so I haven't made the effort to find it
like are you friends with the bachelor
girls on Facebook I think Raven might be
the only friend I have that is so
embarrassing
like it's the people in friends with on
Facebook who I know the people that I
like text today not friends with on
these yeah I think it's like all back in
the day but I will say however when I
was going on the show I went through
Facebook and like was like delete that
picture gotta gotta clean my facebook
out which is a psychology sure yeah and
it's like going into politics like yeah
they're gonna go through everything yeah
interesting yeah my mom is big on
Facebook maybe that's another reason I'm
not true well I'm a big on Facebook now
because we have all these toaster groups
there's like 200 subgroups and Everett
and we just like talk all day it's
really really fun but if it weren't for
that I wouldn't even have these without
my phone so Millennials use Facebook
okay nope I think some Millennials
some Millennials use Facebook the
generation above does and the generation
below does not okay that's where I think
we're at it's just crazy how times like
change there was a time where I couldn't
like not be on Facebook oh no like a
crazy person
yeah it started when I was in college
yeah and I remember fighting it and then
I'm yeah I remember I did the same thing
with Instagram like oh no I don't have
to do Instagram and now I'm like what
was I thinking right imagine if you
never made an Instagram I know and I
didn't even have a Twitter when I
started The Bachelor that's why I'm
terrible on Twitter yeah I don't have a
Twitter anymore oh you don't I just
think it's way too negative place for me
so mean like it's so mean and I believe
my Twitter and then I was like when I
was thinking about making work when I
didn't have a Twitter I would have like
a thought that was funny and I was like
oh I should tweet that and then I
realized all those things I was thinking
we're like also mean and negative that
was me out there like I remember I was
watching pitch perfect 3 and I like this
is trash I should tweet about it and
like I don't have to do no one like no
one needs to hear
just remain pitch perfect for you as
trash oh my god I thought it was so I
thought the second one was the worst the
third one was better than the second one
so I only saw the second one once in
theaters and I didn't think it was good
and I thought they were real I'd way too
much I'm like rebel Wilson like being
fat like they were just throwing her at
every problem don't you think that in
sequels they exaggerated what was so
great in the first way and then that's
what makes it so awful and also the
problem with sequels is that in the end
of the first movie you get what you want
and the only way for the sequel to be
interesting is it has to be undone yeah
and it's like I don't want to see Troy
and Gabriella fighting at the Country
Club and do you watch Hallmark Christmas
I do not oh my god so they're like a
special kind of amazing but Netflix is
now getting into the Christmas movie
game really and they came out with one
last year that was amazing because if
they do the hallmark movies but they
have like big-budget so we're really
seeing real castle okay I'm gonna have
to give him yeah so there was one called
a Christmas Prince and they're releasing
it just it was announced yesterday
they're releasing a sequel to it like
this holiday season gonna be good Jackie
right because the couple is gonna have
to fight it's not gonna be good yeah I
haven't seen a good sequel since home
alone - yeah oh I think I'm gonna have
to go ahead and put that out there and
now I have to think I remember I saw a
good sequel recently but I can't
remember what it was it must have not
been that
and like a wonder woman's coming out
with a seat actually I don't know
because like that it'll just be like a
whole new store it'll be like Wonder
Woman one and hopefully maybe she'll
like find a man even though I know it's
not what Wonder Woman's about but like
Chris Pine was so cute he was so cute
that's why I'm like I kind of like the
way it ended and then why does he have
to spoiler alert the spoiler alert died
like couldn't he just have been wearing
a parachute and jump out I think he was
too high up that's a good point
yeah what other I'm trying to think I
feel like I saw a good sequel recently
but I can't remember also hangover 2 was
not good terrible but 3 was very good I
think 3 was very good because 2 was so
bad yeah that's how I feel about pitch
perfect I mean it wasn't very good 3 but
it was better than 2 I just thought
there were something so weird about
pitch perfect 3 it was like it I don't
know maybe I if I gave it another chance
it was the rebel Wilson fighting at the
end and like her dad was so random yeah
it was also weird um also like High
School Musical is very similar to thing
over like 2 was not good but 3 was
amazing brought us home never seen one
two or three what I know and well now
it's like you would probably be like
what am i watching yeah I don't think I
could do it but and I don't watch the
Lord of the Rings I don't do Harry
Potter so I haven't seen any of those
like trilogy yeah me neither
yeah like too scary like I can't I do
watch Game of Thrones oh no I don't it's
really good I know I feel like I really
have to invest time and do you do you
need like to you don't have the time
yeah I'll tell you I don't I mean when
you're like on the plane and stuff what
do you watch on the plane um I actually
work on planes Wow because that's that's
when you know you're busy that's like
the time I have maybe I'll catch a movie
but I typically work have you seen the
greatest showmen no is that good it's
the best movie of all I like it didn't
get a lot of height well so this is what
happened it came out and initially it
like I got it was not well-received
critically yeah
but then like eight and it didn't do so
well in its opening weekend but over the
weeks like people like word-of-mouth got
out and like it's such a good family
movie the album was number one on the
iTunes charts charts for like six months
really the music is amazing do you
like movie music yeah that's why I'm
really in the stars oh my god the mess
star is born' you liked it I loved it
now this is what I will say if it had
been like a fashion designer meets a
doctor it wouldn't have been good right
it's the lyrics in the movie that make
it so good it's the music have you seen
the other ones no me neither so I I saw
stars born and I didn't know anything
about what it was about mhm and so I was
just like so interesting so I'm like
where is this story going
I didn't even when they first kissed I
was like what I thought you're gonna
help with the music like I didn't know I
didn't even know I didn't even know was
a love story truly and so I was just so
interested the music was so good and I
really enjoyed it then I saw it again
knowing what happens and I enjoyed it
even more yeah because then I saw like
the love connection and like these two
people then I watched but the whole time
I was thinking like what is the message
of this movie like what is the takeaway
and then I watched the Judy Garland one
and again I was just like this is not a
story that needs to be retold now four
times like what even is like you know
it's his directorial debut so it's like
maybe is easier for him to do it like do
a third time but here's my real question
who was the star that was born to you
Gaga or Bradley Cooper oh well okay
the star that was born was Ali but it
was also Bradley like Bradley Cooper was
amazing do you think that he was the
star that was born because he directed
it because I felt like we were watching
him more I mean like she's amazing and
obviously mute like music wise it was
she was the moving but I felt like it
was as far as the script was concerned
it was him as the star well I'm of two
minds because at first I thought she did
such a good job and then I heard like
there are some line items that basically
are acting was so terrible that it was
like they cut and pasted it everywhere
that's why everything is so close up and
then I don't I don't notice like
cinematography unless it's like making
me nauseous like Magic Mike was like
shot in like an Instagram filter and I
was like why is this like so hipster
like it's magic more to see it bad okay
um so then I was like
there were some things I liked about the
the producing what the stuff that
Bradley Cooper did like I loved how they
did it like at Coachella and that glass
and Marian those were like real crowds
like I thought that we know that should
they would like take five minutes from a
set at glass and married like and sing
their song and get offstage and then at
Coachella when she was the headliner
today like put out a memo to like the
her fans they were like if you want to
come to a free Gaga show like dress
country-western we're filming a movie I
did not know that I know and I was at
hotel that year and I'm the biggest Gaga
fan so I don't know how an or mm oh and
I'm a country-western where like where
do I sign up like so at that person
selfishly I'm upset so I liked elements
of it but then when I saw the second
time I was like yeah it really is like a
lot of face and I don't know how much I
love that and that's what I was like
what is his first time right so maybe
that's why I did not like how the movie
was shot at all I noticed that from like
the beginning I mean like I'm a director
or something but I was like if I didn't
like it yeah look and then the music
would save me she's saying I'd be like
okay you brought me back the album is
amazing what was your favorite song I'll
never love again and this is why spoiler
alert spoiler alert we already spoiled
it on the show and people even after
saying spoiler where people were upset
okay and they always are you can't
please everyone when she's singing at
the end the film version cuz you know
there's two versions of I'll never love
again the film version and it cuts to
him saying to her that moves me in in a
way I can't even I could cry
I can't even speak about that's why that
song is my favorite CD you cry during
movie you know it bloodshot red eyes
baby at one point and I was trying to
like cover my face and Brian like moved
my jacket down I was like yes I'm crying
stop that's it so fun but I mean like oh
wow like that oh wow I haven't had a cry
like that in a movie
I've cheered in a few like I teared the
first time I saw a greater showman and
wonder I gotta see this I'm not I'm not
touching wonder and the pursuit of
happiness like I was like sick crying
like cry like everything which part
though I don't I was like so long ago
it was everything I can it was when he
had to pretend that they were running
away
someone and he was bit they didn't have
a place to sleep and they slept in the
bathroom and he I lost it she lost it I
lost it I haven't cried that hard though
in a movie since Titanic interesting I
hadn't realized that I'd never saw
Titanic in full cause like we weren't
really allowed to because there was like
nudity and stuff until like a year ago I
was like we went we were in the Bahamas
on a family trip and I got so sick
hungover I love when people are like I'm
sick you're hungry but I was so sick and
I couldn't go out and Titanic was on and
it was like four hours with commercials
and I watched the whole thing from
beginning to end and like I loved it so
much that I didn't cried probably
because I knew what was coming and that
she could have sit on the door she
couldn't fit on the door moved over they
couldn't make the whole movie was was
good until that point it was like could
she be on like a log or something I
don't know more realistic right that
wide open there's like this whole
conspiracy that she that he could have
fit on the door and then like recently I
saw him meme that had like a picture of
like Kate Winslet's foot and it looked
and massive and then someone was like oh
now I know why he couldn't put on the
door I will I will it's so funny so
maybe he really couldn't have okay I'm
gonna take some viewer questions from
you because I know you have to go you're
a very busy person I'm speaking of being
busy how do you manage your time I know
we talked about this a little bit but
like what are some of your keys so we
just like managing your time and and
just like staying calm cool and
collected but you always seem to be I
thank you I really just take advantage
of every single moment that I have like
we were talking about on the plane
rather than watch movie or sleeping I
use that opportunity to work I carry my
laptop with me everywhere so if I'm like
in a uber or something I'm working I do
it every single second which is the
Mickey nauseous actually looking at my
phone makes me nauseous him not on the
computer but my phone does and that came
late in age like after 30 turning 30 you
guys
I started getting carsick never before I
started getting cars they got like 21
and now it's it's tort like I show up
everywhere ready to throw up yeah I was
like am I hung over no you're old very
similar
what's the vibe like living with all of
the bachelor girls in Dallas and my to
this question is like would you guys
ever do a reality TV show together and
have you been approached okay
these are such great questions so my
master plan was always to get everybody
to Dallas and now I'm never there so it
kind of sucked like Alexis literally
texted me yesterday and said can we go
to lunch and get drunk like I know I'm
never there so I hate that because you
think that we hang out and kick it all
the time I never see raving like Ravens
on our way to China or she's already
there right now or there's some Shanghai
I don't know I don't know
I'm sure graphically challenged yeah she
and Adam wit it was like a birthday
present for her yeah but since she's
gonna do business while she's there it's
great I'm super excited for her but I
need to do better hanging out with the
bachelor girls as far as a reality show
we've talked about it like someone
mentioned on Twitter that we should do
something about our businesses like what
I do with sports and law Rayven and
clothing and then Alexis with the
jewelry I was like that's a really good
idea we haven't actually been approached
but there is something brewing there
yeah there's something there and once
you put it out into the universe yeah
you never know and you just never know
watches the toast like the toasters are
so well connected and like in tune with
what's necessary that just someone out
there just think about it what would you
have done if when we had Peter on the
show if we really had brought you here I
think you would have been so
disappointed it would have been so
uneventful no totally I would have been
like totally would have been a southern
like Belle I would have been like so
nice about it I would have smiled nodded
but not like a teeth smile like a it's
good to see good nice to see you a nod
and probably walked out of the room
you know like would you talk to us again
yeah I would cuz like I would have been
like you're doing it for the show it's
funny like I get it for you guys it's
funny but I wouldn't have given it
anything like I wouldn't have been
dramatic I wouldn't have probably even
hugged him you know but I would have
spoken and I would hello you know like
hope you're doing well type thing for
sure and peace out
well yeah I'm glad we have you guys
separately because then we can just well
I get both of you separately I get to
enjoy it um what's your favorite thing
you've learned about Brian's
the show hello my favorite thing - Brian
really the same way he was on the show
he he was off-camera but he's kind of
goofy and I think that that because he
was such a like a smooth talker total
show and he is he's very charming
but he's really kind of goofy and silly
that he he's shy - which you also really
didn't see on the show now we also
didn't see you could have Brian here you
have love - he's really goofy with me
and I like that yeah because I'm kind of
corny yeah no that's that's like one of
my favorite things about them that's
cute you get you a man who can do both
yeah what advice you have for women in
the workplace trying to advance their
career I'd say sounds so cliche but like
follow your dreams but like to build on
that I always say that I was in a box
when I was you know when I think about
what would you be doing right now I'd
literally be in my office on my computer
writing a motion or something compared
to like sitting on the toast you know
what I mean right now getting on the
toes ice skating with robot yeah it's
like it's crazy but I still do other
stuff but it's like because I stepped
outside of that box and really was like
I'm going to take advantage of the
opportunities that come in front of me
I'm gonna follow my dreams I'm gonna
work hard to pursue it and now I'm like
happier than ever and I think like two
years ago that was not the situation it
was kind of in a rut so I say like step
out of the box don't be afraid to pursue
what you're going to and it's like never
too late to do it totally yeah a yes to
life that's a t-shirt totally except
like I think okay I think I pretty much
say yes like there's nothing I wouldn't
like try once yeah separate coming out
of the plane I don't think I can do that
either when I see people do it oh my
gosh that's so liberating but no like I
I can't think of anything worse I think
I would actually die of a heart attack
like I can't even go like Zach was like
do you want to go to the top of the
Empire State Building if I can get us
and I was like no I don't like Heights I
see I can do that I have vertigo I don't
like being on like my floor I think I
have vertigo I bet I'm just like she
doesn't I'm mostly looks like no at
concerts if I have like really I can't
say they know where to go no I'm like
still that's funny I won't say Santos
leads either I'm like there
I'm bougie about three things hotels
concert seats and sporting events I have
to have like a good seat well that must
be easy for you now living an influencer
life and being a sportscaster pretty
much yeah
well I know you have to run to your next
no your next event on the agenda today
yes thank you so much for being here we
love you so much we're so proud of
everything that you're doing and just
keep killing it and like enjoy your life
you keep killing it okay thank you oh no
oh no I don't know ma what's gonna be
your oh my god we have this question
view what's gonna be your running
hashtag maybe our and be like oh yeah
cheesy but it is what we are know and
Claudie and i were saying this on the
show like we got wedding hot shots have
gotten so far from what they were
originally intended to be that like Zach
a nice couple name is Zach EO and I was
like that can't be our hashtag we need
it to be like Zach sounds his jackpot
like no and it's like couple name even
like Claudian Ben R&B is perfect all
right and then it has all you've hashed
hide it on other couple photos yeah and
it's like a catalogue of your journey
together yeah maybe we'll try to think
of something cuter but right now it's
like R&B no I'm here for it don't like I
for six months I didn't have a hashtag
cuz I couldn't think of anything like
but it was right in front of me the
whole time but they're gonna be like 25
people at our wedding like who's gonna
be hashtag me that's true but engagement
pictures are you gonna have a
bachelorette hashtag oh I have to that's
a good one I need to start working on
that yeah that's a fun one there are so
many fun things you could do anyways
thank you thank you guys for bringing
this are we relate we will be back
tomorrow
I believe in Libya's co-hosting with me
but TBD so see you then
[Music]
you